starting this hour off is going to be
Daphne in Virginia hi Daphne how are you
hi mr. Ramsey thanks for taking our call
and feel free to traipse throughout our
entire house with your muddy shoes
Thanks
hopefully I don't need to how can I help
you need to well I am disabled my
husband is the only one that works in
the house and for 34 for 31 years we've
been struggling and he got a much better
paying job I thought there's no way we
can't make it now but we are still being
overdrawn before every pay period and hi
I'm just at my wit's end because I've
made a budget I've crunched numbers and
I'm not only a saver I'm a tightwad oh
so what does he make he makes two
thousand six hundred and eighty dollars
a month now that's after taxes and
deductions okay and what do you have
coming in on disability I don't have
anything because I'm not eligible
anymore based on his income okay well
I'm sorry no Medicaid as well okay and
what is the nature of your disability
I'm legally blind and I had multiple
sclerosis but I'm willing to work I mean
I would give my eyeteeth to work I want
to help out but work out in the middle
of nowhere I'm thinking if we'd moved to
Tennessee where my son is
I could I could clean houses and make
$100 a day for five days that's 500
extra dollars a week and he could get a
job he is a communications officer and I
mean how old are you guys I'm 51 and
he's 55 what keeps you from doing that
where you are and we're out in the
middle of nowhere
the Department for the blind and
vision-impaired says that I'm too far
out to have a job if I was closer and
town that maybe just maybe you know I
could get a job online medical
transcription or things of that nature I
used to be a custodian until the MS hit
me
well ms is obviously very debilitating
or can be so I'm not sure how you're
gonna clean houses if you can't do I'm
very stubborn and and I can do it I just
I just need the opportunity to do it so
I need all the bells that you have now
total more than twenty-six hundred
ninety dollars a month yes I did a
budget and after the budget we have
thirteen dollars a month to nothing so
what is one of the big items in the
budget how much is your rent
we don't pay rent our house is free and
clear we got on a free foreclosure okay
that's wonderful
what is it worth our house as is right
now is 225 okay excellent
okay that's wonderful all right yes and
so what are what are your what are your
big items in your budget then the big
items is his car is 364 a month which he
owes seventeen thousand won and his
student loan which he wanted to go to
school and I didn't have the heart to
tell him he was too old I'm Peyton he's
in default and I'm paying 131 a month
it's 95 thousand those are the two
biggest things
well 9595 and 360 do not take all of
twenty six hundred obviously you gotta
buy food and you have to buy lights and
water where's the rest of this going
okay I'll read it down to you real quick
all right
364 car 300 electric auto insurance 192
home insurance 174 phone an Internet 119
cell phone $90 for two my husband is
fund taxes 75 a month gas 200 a month
told seventy a month groceries 600 a
month credit cards 120 a month my life
insurance 40 a month 131 for student
loan and garbage is 35
Oh in our medical bills our 107 point
zero zero and that's every month sure
okay
unless your income comes up he would
need to sell this car because the car
doesn't fit
we are absolutely talking about that
right now and we are selling everything
it's not bolted down I've already we've
already put it on Facebook marketplace
Craigslist and another site that he not
complete the school when he started no
he bless his heart my husband has the
vision he doesn't have the endurance I'd
have no vision but I have insurance we
enable each other okay well the move
into an area where you can do some
things to get your incomes up would
obviously help you getting rare the car
would obviously help you you've done a
great job laying out the budget so
nothing I heard on there sounded abusive
or completely out of line are there
would anything there to pick on other
than by far your biggest bills are three
hundred sixty dollar car payment on a
seventeen thousand on a car for a guy
that makes thirty five thousand dollars
a year and that doesn't that just
doesn't fit this car is and does not fit
in this income structure now if he's
doing something to get his income up and
you know that kind of stuff then that's
great we can talk about different things
then but he needs to double his income
if we're talking about keeping this car
otherwise it needs to go so those are
some things you can do but you're you're
you're doing pretty well
on a very low income is what it amounts
to and you've just made a couple of
mistakes with the credit cards and the
student loans and the car and it's going
to take a while to dig through those but
if you can get rid of those credit cards
and this car payment it's going a long
way towards straightening this around
and then from there let's talk about
what we can do to get incomes up in the
household with career changes and
reasonable ideas you got some challenges
no doubt about it kiddo if I can help
you you call me anytime that's what
we're here for so there's two sides to
this equation it's a fairly simple
equation on your budget the income side
and the outgo side
most people they call this show it's an
out go problem but sometimes like Daphne
it's an income problem and she's got
some legitimate things limiting our
ability to create an income it's not a
lack of she's not lazy it's not a lack
of being willing to work its lack of
finding something that fits in the the
disabilities and the challenges that
she's got so it's a process but all of
us can look and say gosh ten years from
now what can I be doing where I made
twice as much money what have I got to
do what has to be true that's not true
today do I need to take a class do I
need to get a degree do I need to be in
an apprentice program do I need to read
every book I can get my hands on on the
subject probably what is it you want to
do with your life what can you do to
create income in the process sometimes
that's a bigger part of the equation